he tubers is Charlie so arrow dropped a
whole bunch of teasers for the hundredth
episode that you can see what they're
doing it's been a black canary green
arrow wedding from the comics so I'll
also explain that storyline because
that's not exactly what arrows doing but
that's kind of the joke they're going
for with this so for all of you
collectively mouthing wTF is going on
the hundredth episode is supposed to be
a parallel reality where Oliver wakes up
to a world where he never got on the
Queen's Gambit that's why you see Sarah
in these photos because she got on the
Queen's Gambit with him Robert Queen is
here and because Rey is here I think
this is meant to be in present day in
this alternate reality but here's the
synopsis so I'll just read this it
doesn't give away too much but it gives
you kind of an idea it says arrow
celebrates 100 episodes the epic
superhero crossover continues because
this is the third night of the four
night crossover Oliver wakes up to a
life where he never got on the Queen's
Gambit Robert and Moira queen are alive
and well Laurel is his loving fiancee in
their wedding is imminent everything
seems perfect but Oliver starts to
notice imperfections that make him
question this new reality meanwhile
Felicity and the recruits take on a new
threat with the help of the flash and
Supergirl so what it sounds like is
happening you know Batman perchance to
dream style you have Oliver in this fake
reality at the mercy of the dominators
while the rest of the team in real time
like in the real world are trying to
defeat the dominators so as you would
expect he starts to realize that the
reality that he's in isn't real
he comes out and we've seen like a
couple clips from the four night
crossover where he's firing dominator
weapons like on one of their ships so
maybe he's in like one of these pods or
something like that wakes up and just
starts going crazy on everyone and
everything goes back to normal with him
trying to get them off the planet but
for the most part when they said they
tried to represent every big character
that had ever been on arrow
in the hundredth episode most of that
seems like it's gonna take place in this
dream land where Oliver is getting ready
to get married to Laurel but for the
most part there are a couple big things
that are missing in these pictures that
we don't know about Merlyn would be
there he's probably in the episode
somewhere but he had already gone to
join the League of Assassins
independently of Oliver and Robert and
Sarah getting on the Queen's Gambit so
whenever we see Merlin they'll have to
address what's going on with the
undertaking because Moira was tied up in
all that in season one independently of
what was going on with Robert but
speaking of Merlin the other big thing
now Tommy is still alive because he died
when Oliver went to war with Merlin he
died because of all that undertaking
craziness so if the dominators are
recreating Oliver's life in like
presenting him with like a really
saccharine version of what it might have
been like then I'm wondering if the
undertaking is still going to happen but
I'm assuming not because Oliver probably
realizes that like some of the people he
runs into in this dreamland are either
dead or super evil so it'll be funny to
see like the clues that he starts to
recognize that let him know that this is
not the reality that he's supposed to be
in the other thing about this too is
like you see the idea of Oliver getting
married to Laurel and you think about
Black Canary getting married to green
arrow in the comics this isn't
necessarily that because Oliver would
not have become the green arrow had he
not gotten on the Queen's Gambit so
there's no green arrow
Sarah would not have joined the League
of Assassins had she not got on so
there's no original Black Canary to
inspire Laurel to become the Black
Canary herself so in this reality here
you're - like a couple really big super
heroes so this isn't necessarily a comic
book II thing but just to explain that
storyline though what happened is is
that Green Arrow had his own solo series
at the end of that run he proposed to
Black Canary so this wedding special
issue was like the beginning of their
ongoing series together Green Arrow and
Black Canary
that was like an ongoing series but the
big twist is is that the Amazons had
replaced all of her with everyman a
shape changer because after their
wedding wedding night you know great
they're gonna go have sex it's gonna be
awesome but he starts to go crazy and
attacks her and she's like Ollie why are
you attacking us on our wedding night so
you learned that it was really every man
it was an imposter in that big WTF
moment led into their ongoing series so
the funny thing is is like
this arrow wedding is meant to be fake
it's like happening on Oliver's head but
in the comics it was kind of fake too so
that's the big twist be you guys can let
me know what you think about all this
you can see how they've kind of like
shoehorned in some of the other
characters to this dreamland like if
Oliver were experiencing this like super
sweet
dreamland that was meant to trap him he
probably wouldn't be dreaming of Ray
Palmer but because it's during the big
four night crossover you have to have
like all the characters in there
somewhere so you have like the dreamland
then you have the stuff happening in
real life so I'm not expecting Oliver to
spend the entire episode in this false
reality you know maybe most the episode
maybe like half of it but you guys can
let me know in the comments what do you
think is the final thing the tips
Oliver off that this is all fake they're
going from like one end of the crazy
spectrum to the complete opposite so I'm
not a super big fan of weddings on arrow
but I think the rest of the episode will
be a lot of fun I mean it is fun to see
Laurel back but if we're gonna get
Laurel back I would rather her be like
metahuman Black Canary but none of this
answers the question as to how Laurel is
coming back in the back half of the
season so like she's supposed to show up
during episode 10 but we don't know how
that's going to happen and that's also
supposed to coincide with Talia al Ghul
coming on the TV show so even though
we're seeing a bunch of crazy hundredth
episode stuff that says nothing about
what's going to be happening in the back
half of the season
so because arrow is on break next week
what they might do is just release more
footage of this so this episode of arrow
like the big four night crossover isn't
happening for two weeks next week
there's only Supergirl and flash
everything else is on break so I'll
remind everyone what's going on when I
post my flash video next week but there
is a new round of the DC giveaway it's a
$20 Amazon gift card all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so what I'm gonna
do next
is post a Deadpool video Ryan Reynolds
set a whole bunch of funny stuff in an
interview about the original Deadpool
character that he did during Wolverine
Origins about the Deadpool movie the
Deadpool sequel so a whole bunch of
Deadpool coming in a little while well
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the trailer for the big
four night crossover and you
click here for the trailer for the next
episode of the flash the killer frost
episode thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight